[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen zu Sallys Welt
wir haben gerade November das sage ich
weil ich weiß dass wir das Video erst
später ausstrahlen werden nämlich im
neuen Jahr und wir haben noch
Weihnachtsdeko aber das Video ist super
wichtig denn morgen um 14 Uhr Wember
wird die Samira 10 Jahre alt schon sehen
ich kann es nicht glauben mein großes
Baby wird sehen
irgendwie ist so jedes Jahr und dann
zwei stelle ich es halt noch mal so
ein Signal an die Mama ich werde gross
und ja dieses Jahr ist natürlich leider
so das ist natürlich keine große Party
gefeiert wird sondern wir bleiben
wirklich nur unter uns also wir zu viert
Samira muratella ich und natürlich gibt
gibt trotzdem eine schöne Torte Samira
liebt Donuts und deswegen habe ich mir
gedacht mache ich einen tripcake mit
Donuts drauf nicht ob darüber wird sie
sich sehr freuen und dann gibt einfach
morgen zum Samstag einfach die
Überraschung zu Hause vielleicht schaffe
ich es ja auch bisschen was im Handy mit
zu filmen und
wert meiner kleinen großen Maus eben
trotzdem ne Überraschung bereiten was
ich jetzt hier machen werde ist
folgendes ich habe meinen Mandel
Rührteig den gibt's ja schon als Basic
Rezept ich zeige hier die Zutaten ich
mache die doppelte Menge denn die Torte
soll im Durchmesser 20 cm klein sein
oder groß sein eher ne höhere Torte und
habe hier deswegen praktisch die Menge
für 2 Böden dich auch gleichzeitig
backen werde und wird es ganzer mit
Konfetti Streusel noch Zubereiten von
der Anleitung her könnte gerne im Basic
Rezept auch nachschauen und ich nehme
jetzt dafür sechs Eier die sind bereits
zimmerwarm 150 g Zucker 1 Prise Salz
etwas Tonka Wonka für den Geschmack
jeweils 300g Mineralwasser oder
Buttermilch und Sonnenblumenöl
450 g Mehl 200 g Mandeln die sind
bereits geschält die werden gleich
gemahlen und Päckchen Backpulver das
sind 3 Teelöffel und 100g Konfetti
Streusel und hier habe ich es einfach
die halbe Zuckermenge also ich nehme den
basic Teig mit reduzierte Zuckermenge
denn die Torte wird auch schon süß und
dann passt denke ich direkt denn die
Konfetti sind die auch gesüßt und dann
ist die Torte nicht so süß so erzählt
dir jetzt die Eier mit dem Zucker Salz &
Tonka Wonka Stadt Tonka Wonka könnt ihr
auch eine Tonkabohne einfach dazu
schreiben ne kleine Prise und die
Zutaten werden jetzt schön cremig
verrührt das dauert ungefähr 10 bis 15
Minuten in der Zwischenzeit könnt ihr
schonmal die Mandeln fein mahlen und das
Backpulver mit dem Mehl vermischen jetzt
kommen noch die beiden Flüssigkeiten
vorsichtig zum Teig und werden ganz kurz
eingerührt und anschließend folgen schon
die trockenen Zutaten die ich ganz kurz
mit dem Schneebesen unterrühren ich
möchte gerne kleinere hohe Torte haben
und deswegen bereite ich schon die 2Pac
regele vor mit 18 cm Durchmesser jetzt
könnt ihr noch die Konfetti Streusel
dazugeben und den fertigen Teig in die
zwei vorbereiteten backringe füllen die
habe ich jetzt hier mit Backpapier
umschlagen weil der Teig doch relativ
flüssig ist
ihr seht schon das Recht viel Teig
deswegen Streich dir jetzt hier noch im
Rand hoch damit er schön gleichmäßig
Park den damit du nicht reißt
und jetzt kann ich beide Teige backen
und dann schon direkt die Donuts
vorbereiten
[Musik]
die Donuts werden jetzt nicht wie auf
einem Kanal aus Hefeteig gemacht und
frittiert ich mache jetzt bisschen
einfacher weil ich auch denke dass diese
Thomas richtig cool auf der Torte
aussehen ich nehme einfach so eine Donut
Backform und machen den kleinen Rührteig
also wie bei Muffins dafür nehme ich
hier 150 Gramm Zucker etwas Salz 200g
Mehl und ein Teelöffel Backpulver zwei
Eier Vanilleextrakt und jeweils ungefähr
100 ml
Sonnenblumenöl und Olivenöl nein
Orangensaft danke Orangensaft vielleicht
brauche ich es nicht komplett nass ist
immer drauf an wie groß die Eier sind
und dafür braucht ja auch wirklich gar
kein handdruckgerät sondern ihr verrührt
die trockenen Zutaten in einer Schüssel
wirklich super schnell also wenn ich mal
schnell was backen will sind Muffins
eigentlich immer so die beste Antwort
darauf
und dann für ruhig hier in der Schüssel
die Eier mit dem Vanilleextrakt
gebe etwas Orangensaft dazu ihr könnt
auch Milch verwenden oder wieder
Mineralwasser das Öl das Öl brauche ich
komplett und beim Saft schaue ich
einfach wie viel ich brauche
perfekt und dann einfach beides
vermischen
so schnell geht das
jetzt merke ich schon okay ein bisschen
fest ist der Teig
also nehme ich doch den Orangensaft noch
ich muss sagen der riecht schon richtig
gut wegen Orangensaft und Vanille wie
Fanta Cupcakes nur eben ohne Fanta also
praktisch aus 100% Orangensaft
aber da Samira werde ich verkaufen als
Fanta Donuts
da freut sie sich
und die Farbe ist er dadurch auch in
echt cool so
wie gesagt nur Donut Backform die kurz
einfetten
dann den Teig einfüllen entweder mit dem
Spritzbeutel oder hier so direkt
[Musik]
und die Form einfach fast bis unter den
Rand füllen also ein bisschen auslassen
so 2-3 mm
[Musik]
electric fahrbereites
ja aus dem Rest mache ich dir einen
Tassenkuchen
ja wenn meine Mikrowelle ist nicht
belegt wer hier die ist einfach in der
Mikrowelle gebacken so 3 Minuten
Tassenkuchen
ja jetzt nicht in Ehrwald
ich habe auch noch eine Minute und dann
packe ich es damit rein
[Musik]
jetzt bin ich hier soweit also die
Tortenböden sind gebacken ich habe sie
abkühlen lassen und dann auch noch mal
im Kühlschrank gestellt damit ich sie
gleich gut schneiden kann die Donut sind
auch fertig ich finde die sehen echt
perfekt aus
Yoshi Tassenkuchen mit Nougat ist auch
fertig wegen Gasvergleich probieren und
jetzt wird eine Buttercreme hergestellt
weil ich später dann fit machen will da
sind Buttercreme seid generell besser
geeignet weil die Buttercreme schon fest
wird der Trip runter laufen kann und
entweder könnte jetzt eine Buttercreme
von meinem Kanal machen Swiss Meringue
buttercream deutsche Buttercreme
französische Buttercreme italienische
Buttercreme was ihr möchtet ich muss
sagen ich habe heute echt wenig Zeit und
dadurch dass ich ja noch viel Arbeit vor
mir habe mir den Donuts ich mache die
Bitterkeit und die schmeckt auch echt
sehr sehr lecker also wie sieht die
Buttercreme zum Anrühren dann nehme ich
hier das Päckchen ich habe auch schon
weiche Butter und da ist es jetzt nur so
hier in der Schüssel geben mit Wasser
vermischen und dann 30 Minuten stehen
lassen ich muss auch sagen bei der habe
ich kein schlechtes Gewissen weil
es halt so wahrschein geht und darf auch
mal was einfaches sein
es sieht es gleich nur ein bisschen aus
wie Kleister das ist aber völlig normal
und
geschmacklich könnt ihr sie gerne noch
verfeinern so schmeckt jetzt erstmal
nach Vanille ich könnte jetzt hier auch
noch am Aromen mit dazu geben wie
zitronenschalenabrieb und Orangenabrieb
oder was auch immer ihr könnt auch in
Fruchtpüree mit einarbeiten einfach
richtig gut eingekocht ist und das lasse
ich jetzt hier einfach mal stehen ich
werde später nämlich einfärben mit
Lebensmittelfarbe und kümmere mich jetzt
erstmal um die Donau und damit geht's
dann später weiter für die Donuts also
die Glasur mache ich jetzt einfach eine
Ganache eine weiße man kann auch zurück
lass so machen aus Puderzucker und
Zitronensaft oder Puderzucker und Wasser
aber ich glaube eine Ganache ist hier in
dem Fall echt ganz gut ich glaube das
sieht gut aus also habe ich jetzt hier
Sahne und Schokolade
kann die Sahne in einem Topf aufkochen
und dann die Schokolade kurz einrühren
und dann werde ich die Garage aber noch
einfärben in ich bin mir noch nicht
sicher ob ich rosa oder blau oder mint
deswegen werde ich ein paar hellrosa
machen und paar bläulich Mint und hier
noch mal die Konfetti Streusel drauf
benutzen ja so ganz habe ich immer im
Kopf nämlich noch nicht wie sie aussieht
also schon so einen Mist und Minz Torte
weißer Trip und dann die Donuts
mal gucken dann ausschalten
[Musik]
bisschen Lebensmittelfarbe Paste dazu
hier muss jetzt sagen das ist jetzt
nicht ganz rosa sondern er soll Lachs
durch die weiße Schokolade die ist
nämlich nicht weiß sondern eher gelblich
wir singen könnt sogar schon immer so
arm ich gebe sie einfach ein bisschen
weise verpasste dazu damit ich wirklich
diesen Gelbstich aus bekomme müsste ich
machen aber für mich optisch macht jetzt
schon Sinn
und jetzt kann ich die Donuts Rhein
tauchen
ich weiß nicht wie es gleich aussehen
wird aber ich hoffe gut
eine Luftblase gebildet
[Musik]
auch schon schön aber ich kann sie
tiefer tauchen
[Musik]
die schönen Donuts habe ich jetzt im
Kühlschrank mache CD Buttercreme weiter
wie gesagt sie ist ein Ausweg Kleister
aber es schmeckt gleich sehr gut und die
Buttercreme die wird auch sehr gut
deshalb hier einfach mit der weichen
Butter schön cremig rühren und auch hier
gebe ich ein bisschen verpasse dazu
damit sondern mintfarbene Buttercreme
wird aber das mache ich erst wenn die
Torte gefüllt ist innen lasse ich sie
glaube ich hell und außen Mint ich
überleg es mir gleich ich habe jetzt
erstmal
[Musik]
als nächstes kann ich jetzt hier die
Tortenböden raus lösen
es geht am besten mit so einem
tortenringmesser mit einem Backform
Messer
[Musik]
dann stürze ich die Böden hier raus und
kann sie einfach mal mit der tortensäge
durchschneiden schöne dünne Böden
[Musik]
jetzt wird die Torte gefüllt wie gesagt
nämlich jetzt eine Marmelade ich habe
hier einfach so eine gemischte aus
erdbeer-himbeer Aprikose zu alle
Marmeladen Reste die ich gefunden habe
zusammengemischt soll mal ganz gut weil
man so alle Gäste im Kühlschrank
bisschen verbrauchen kann
und dann wird jetzt hier im Wechsel mit
der Buttercreme die Pforte einfach schön
gefüllt und anschließend gekühlt und
danach kann ich sie dann außen eben
glatt streichen
mit acht Eimer drauf dass ich die Creme
schön glatt Streiche also kein Hubel
denn wenn jetzt in Rubel formt wird
natürlich der nächste Boden auch nicht
glatt also immer schön gerade
[Musik]
guckt mal den obersten Boden also diesen
Hubbel den lege ich meist so rum drauf
da mich einfach immer schön gerade
weiter machen kann und den Abschluss
bildet dann noch mal dieser flacher
Boden
dann ist es noch schöne hohe Torte
[Musik]
den Rand glätte ich jetzt einmal kurz
mit einer Teigkarte
jetzt könnt ihr die Torte so einfach in
den Kühlschrank stellen ich werde
allerdings kurz einpacken einmal mit
Folie die kann ich wieder benutzen und
mit dem hund Tortenring damit sie
einfach so bisschen an Stabilität
gewinnt es wird aber auch so gehen nur
so bekommt sie schon mal gleich eine
richtige perfekte runde Form
Zack und sobald die gekühlt ist geht's
damit direkt weiter und ich kann in der
Zwischenzeit aufräumen
kann ich hier die Torte
die sitzt perfekt gekühlt komplett glatt
streichen
das heißt nämlich hier die restliche
Buttercreme dich habt ihr mich übrigens
bei Raumtemperatur gelagert also nicht
im Kühlschrank
einen Streich die hier an den Rand dann
zuerst den Rand glatt ziehen und dann
eben auch noch die Oberfläche
[Musik]
diese untere Schicht habe ich jetzt helf
und da kommt ja jetzt praktisch die
mintfarbene Schicht drüber und ich werde
es doch schon so bisschen durchschimmern
lassen so im naked steel denn ich habe
gerade überlegt Audi Buttercreme wird
sonst knapp aber doch ich mache
demnächst sehen als jetzt wirklich hier
oben noch kurz glatt machen kühl stellen
die Creme noch einfärben und dann naked
steel also nicht komplett deckend
sondern wirklich so dass die Böden noch
bis zum Durchstöbern dürfen ich habe es
wenn nicht mehr schön bei der Torte
[Musik]
jetzt will die Torte sozusagen kurz
eingefroren damit die weiße Creme fest
wird und sich damit der blaue neben oder
mit der mintfarben nicht vermischt
[Musik]
ich muss sagen
dass mir die Torte so richtig gut
gefällt also ich glaube ich gleite dir
heute echt nicht mache auch
wahrscheinlich keinen Trip dran ich gebe
es jetzt erstmal in Kühlschrank guck mir
noch mal die Donuts an und überleg mir
noch eine Deko
und mach heute eine ohne perfekt perfekt
Torte wirklich so im naked steel
ich werd jetzt noch folgendes machen ich
habe hier weiße Schokolade geschmolzen
ganz wenig und werde jetzt die Dona
aufspießen auf Lolli Sticks damit man
sie so von der Hand essen kann und ich
sie so auch in die Torte stecken kann
als Deko das heißt hier einmal rein
Spesen
aber ich dachte gleich weißt du was
kannst du mir die vorbereiten und ich
mache sie in die Donuts weil ja warte
warte warte warte, du machst dir so
fertig und
ich pack sie in die Donuts rein
sollte man möglichst wenig anfassen
[Musik]
denn sonst beschädigen wir die
Oberfläche
Mäuschen
das ist wahr und du hast da auch recht
aber du kannst mir dir vorbereiten
Teamarbeit bedeutet du bereitest es vor
kürzer für vorne und
das reicht jetzt erstmal die anderen
Donuts möchte ich nämlich erst
fotografieren und danach auf okay das
lassen wir kurz fest werden und ich kann
schon mal meine Torte auf eine
Tortenplatte setzen
David morgen 10 Uhr
gefällt sie dir
du süße möchtest du mal kosten ob die
Torten überhaupt gut ist
ganz vorsichtig
die Torte ja ne
[Musik]
danke du bist so eine gute Motivation
für mich
dann habe ich mir gedacht bisschen
Konfetti so an Rand
[Musik]
und wie alt bist du
zeige ansehen das heißt du bist genauso
alt wie die Samira cool warte warte
guck mal wir machen das so also wir
drehen uns genauso in die Mitte
oder wir machen das hier
[Musik]
also dann habe ich jetzt hier noch diese
Wimpelkette gemacht
muss ich mal gucken wo ich die Platz
hier so voll dran
Neva ich hätte gern die 10 vorne und
jetzt packen wir praktisch
diese Popstar hin
[Musik]
da hätten da oder
was willst Du
warum
[Musik]
nein
kein schnipp schnapp Haare ab das haben
wir jetzt schon oft genug hinter uns
die kleine Fädchen die mache ich noch
weg aber so ist jetzt schon miras
überraschungstorte fertig und sie hat
sich ja gewünscht eine Candy Torte sie
liebt Donut und ich glaube ich mein gut
kennen die habe ich jetzt nicht drauf
aber ich glaub mir Donut Torte so was
ist sie halt auch gar nicht eingefallen
und ich hoffe sie freut sich morgen mein
kleines Baby wird schon sehen ich denke
mir dann immer so krass wenn Sie das in
zehn Jahren anschaut dann steht 20 und
er hat also 15 Uhr so voll Teenager und
ich soll 29
man die Zeit vergeht so schnell und
wisst ihr was ich cool finde ich wenn
ich habe schon ich weiß kann jetzt an
der Stelle sagen ja wir schon manchmal
überlegt wenn ich am Anfang gewusst
hätte wie groß der Kanal mal wird und
keine Ahnung das einfach so diese
Bekanntheit größer wird weiß ich nicht
ob ich damals so die Kids mit rein
genommen hätte aber es ist halt einfach
so passiert weil ich habe aus der Küche
raus einfach Koch dann gebacken und
Samira hat somit gemacht und Ella ist
doch reingeboren rein gewachsen und
heute denke ich mir so ich meine wir
laden ja echt nur schöne Dinge hoch wie
sie hier naschen und mit backen und wenn
ich mit alte Videos angucken und guck
wie klein die Samira war vor zwei also
das erste Mal oder eineinhalb oder ja
eineinhalb war sie als ich das erste mal
wie das gemacht habe und da war sie so
ein Mini und jetzt sitzt sie einfach
schon zehn und sie kann so ihren ganzen
Prozess einfach in den Videos sehen und
dann weißt Du irgendwann so jetzt meine
Mama die hat immer mit mir gekocht und
gebacken und gebastelt und gebaut und
meine Kinder Küche gekauft und ich
durfte bei meiner Mama immer donnert
naschen denkt sich dann die Ella bevor
es jetzt noch sentimentaler wird sage
ich auf Wiedersehen also die Torte ist
wirklich eine Torte die ihr an einem Tag
superschaft mit bisschen kühl Zeit
und dann wirklich jemanden tolle
Überraschung könnt also happy Birthday
mein kleiner Schatz bis zum nächsten Mal
tschüss
Focus
natürlich damit wir für morgen schon mal
vorkosten können ob es wirklich gut
schmeckt ne guck mal ist überleg mal die
Samira sieht noch irgendwann das Video
möchtest du deiner Schwester was ganz
ganz nettes zum Geburtstag wünschen dann
sprichst mal zum ja in die Kamera und
[Musik]
was wünscht du ihr dass sie immer
glücklich ist oder
und immer gesund und
willst du ihr vielleicht sagen was du
für sie empfindest
was
ob du deine Schwester magst oder liebst
oder gar nicht magst
magst du dich zeigen Absolution ich
liebe dich
Ich liebe dich und
deine Schwester
[Musik]
[Applaus]
happy Birthday
Kerzen auf. Ich glaub schon ist
nicht für mich so stark nicht so stark
und los
[Applaus]
[Musik]